yesterday we covered the hearing of
Attorney General Jeff Sessions and his
testimony before the Senate Intelligence
Committee and I talked about this
technique that Jeff Sessions used when
he didn't want to answer questions about
Trump he would say what when he so
technique one was I don't remember I
don't recall I've forgotten what I
remembered to not know about initially
if it ever happened but what I can
assure you is I never did anything wrong
that was technique number one technique
number two was he would say well I want
to respect the right of Donald Trump to
it some future point maybe invoke
executive privilege if he wants to which
didn't really make any sense because as
I told you yesterday during hearings the
president has what's called executive
privilege if the president is testifying
and he's asked about something he can
invoke executive privilege to avoid
talking about certain things serious
things as Donald Trump likes to say
including what he might consider to have
been a confidential conversation between
him and someone else this can also be
invoked by the president when other
people are testifying like Jeff Sessions
to conversations that they may have had
with the president Trump did not invoke
executive privilege with regard to
anything that Jeff Sessions was asked
about on a Monday or Tuesday I guess it
was so sessions was expected to answer
questions that he was asked basically
every single time sessions was asked
about past conversations with Trump he
refused to answer because he was
preserving Donald Trump's right to
invoke executive privilege maybe in the
future retro actively if he wanted which
is not how executive privilege works
session said it was a Department of
Justice policy not to testify about
conversations with the president but we
when he was asked whether it's an actual
rule he didn't actually explain whether
it was or wasn't here's just a clip of
what went on at that hearing senator I'm
protecting the president's
constitutional right by not on giving it
away
before he has a chance on to your have
you and I currently I am telling the
truth in answering your question in
saying it's a long-standing policy of
the Department of Justice
even and to make sure the president has
full opportunity to decide these issues
can you share those policies with us
well written down at the Department of
Justice I believe they are certainly
appropriate in this legal standard but
I'm answering congressional inquiry it's
the judge my judgment ah that it would
be inappropriate for me to answer and
reveal private conversations with the
president when he has not had a full
opportunity to review the questions and
to make a decision on whether or not to
approve such an answer one there are
also other privileges that could be
invoked sessions was there to talk about
things related to Trump that was the
point of the hearing total gongshow and
Jeff Sessions was trying to have it both
ways he was saying I don't have the
right to invoke executive privilege in
order not to answer your question and
the president has an invoked executive
privilege to prevent me from answering
your question but I'm going to refuse in
the hypothetical case that Trump would
have seen the questions ahead of time
and might want to retroactively Li
invoke executive privilege and it's not
the case that Trump didn't have the
opportunity to invoke executive
privilege this hearing was on the books
for a little while yeah I mean if you've
got to make a decision and people are
going to make assumptions and their own
decisions based off of your decision of
course so this doesn't really work and
endless legal experts have said Jeff
Sessions has no idea what he's talking
about start with Asha Rangga pas
Associate Dean at Yale Law School who
said executive privilege even if it
applies in this case can only be invoked
by the president sessions cannot
preemptively invoke it on the
president's behalf second I'm not sure
what Department of Justice policy has to
do with this DOJ policy is an internal
executive branch regulation it does not
provide a legal shield against
testifying in Congress when it is
conducting an investigation as part of
its oversight function basically saying
whether or not the policy was written
down as jeff sessions seemed unable to
answer it doesn't matter because he's
not legally relevant to this type of
testimony then we heard from Lisa Kern
Griffin law professor at Duke University
who said sessions use the indica
nation of vague principles of
confidentiality to his advantage that's
not how it works
in fact general sessions carefully
avoided the phrase executive privilege
and kept referring to confidentiality
this is similar to what occurred during
the testimony of Admiral Rogers and
Director of National Intelligence Coates
Lisa Kern also said that legally
speaking sessions could be held in
contempt of Congress for this that's not
going to happen I don't think we have to
really worry about that but again
something that could happen and also
concurrent concurring with this where
Samuel Gross a law professor at
University of Michigan Dianne mariamman
law professor at the University of
Georgia all legal experts asked about
this Pat said this is bogus right
because jeff sessions not only swore to
tell the truth he also swore to tell the
whole truth that's problem here as we
talked about yesterday though is it's
hard to prove whether or not someone
forgot or was able to remember something
very difficult to prove that legally and
here is senator Heinrich talking to Erin
Burnett after the hearing about what
happened did you walk away from this
trusting him more or not that's the
bottom line
I walked away from this being highly
concerned that there now seems to be a
concerted effort by the administration
trying to obstruct this investigation
and so you think he was obstructing and
impeding today the Attorney General in
that case he wouldn't answer the most
basic questions under oath and we're not
going to be able to get to the bottom of
this entire matter unless we have honest
answers from the administration there it
is
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show